I carry your heart with me,
high county it in my home.
I'm never without it.
Anywhere I go,
you go.
My idea and whatever is done by only me
is your doing my daughter.
I fear no fate for you are my fate,
my suite.
I want no world war.
Beautiful.
You are my world,
my crew and h you a whatever a moon has
always meant and whatever his son will
always saying is you.
Here is the deepest secret.
Nobody knows.
Here is the root of the root and the
Bardo,
the bug and the sky and the sky.
The tree called light which grows higher
than so ken,
Whoa or mind can hide,
and this is the one.
It's keeping the stars a park.
I carry your heart.
I carry it in my house
of all the many highly experimental
poems by e,
e Dot Cummings.
I carry your heart with me.
I carry it in is among the most
straightforward and approachable.
It's the one you're most likely to hear
at weddings or at weddings.
In romcoms.
I carry your heart with me.
I carry it in my heart and because this
poem seems effortless,
it feels pulled out of time too.
I think that was what I wanted to make
this poem,
universal quintessential love poem for
the Modern Age.
I mean,
just take a look at the five concrete
images that he uses.
Hearts,
Moon,
Sun,
tree stars.
It's hard to imagine five symbols more
archetypal,
so the intention here is clearly
universal appeal,
but that's not a slight on the poems.
Construction or it's meaning just the
opposite.
In fact,
as Yates once brilliantly wrote about
his own craft,
align will take us hours maybe yet if it
does not seem a moment's thought,
our stitching and unsticking has been
not.
So.
First,
let's take a look at the formal
construction of I carry your heart.
The first thing to notice is that the
poem is split into two overlapping
parts.
Everything that's outside the
parentheses and everything that's inside
them.
This follows the theme setup in the
first line,
the theme of the narrators lover being
contained within his heart and vice
versa.
This reciprocal relationship is hammered
home in the first stanza with anywhere I
go,
you go and whatever is done by only me
is your doing.
Every statement in this poem is followed
by a parent theoretical statement and
frequently keywords used outside of them
are found inside as well.
Linking the two parts and the two
people.
Parentheses are the perfect punctuation
to use because visually they actually
represent the image of containment.
It's critic Roy.
Tarkovsky has observed cummings find
several poetic functions from the
parentheses throughout his work,
whether it's to convey intimacy or
protection or to give a direct address
to the subject or like we just discussed
to use it's crescent shape as an icon in
itself.
The neatest Tarkovsky notes,
parentheses have a somewhat
contradictory place and all our writing
formally,
they're supposed to contain throwaway
information stuff that would
theoretically be perfectly okay to leave
out what?
Because of this,
because they don't have to be there and
yet still our parents political comments
call attention to themselves for
grounding their content swell,
backgrounding them at the same time.
Ambiguity like that is exactly what
cummings loves to play with and it
reinforces the poems,
themes.
Clearly Cummings is using the parents
medicals for intimacy.
You can see that in his additions of my
dear,
my darling,
my suite,
my true,
but he also uses them to develop his
philosophy of self and love.
See,
for Cummings,
love is a condition in which to
fragmented selves come together to form
a more perfect unity and if there's one
great theme in his collected work,
it's the importance of being a truly
transcendental he alive individual
against the doling and alienating forces
of modern progress,
but the individual self was always a
problematic idea for cummings.
Whereas sometimes he evolved.
That man is a miraculously whole human
being elsewhere.
Like in the same sentence,
he says that man's only happiness is to
transcend himself again and again.
His poetry affirms that transcendence
comes with losing the self in love.
Whether it said gracefully outright,
like when he writes,
losing through you what seemed myself,
I find selves unimaginably mine or it's
demonstrated in some formal fireworks
like in this poem where the you and me
is literally fused together and the
speaker has difficulty determining what
form of the verb is best to use.
Loves ability to transcend is the focus
of I carrier heart and cummings is using
whatever he can to explore it.
Different connotations of transcendence.
Just take a look at the third stanza.
Love is literally a cosmic force that
holds the stars in the firmament,
but it's also the deepest secret and
coming suggests this deepness by
nesting,
the secret in parentheses,
which are themselves nested into the
poem,
and the secret is buried further in the
root of the root and the bud of the bud
and the symbols I mentioned earlier,
son and particularly moon,
are symbols of transcendence throughout
his poetry.
I mean what has the moon always meant to
cummings in a great essay by cummings
critic Martin Hooser,
which I'll link to below the moon.
Significance is traced across several
poems.
It's variously described as a remarkable
splinter,
dainty madden was watch spring,
a balloon,
a big red dog mystery as having small
hands,
and as the shyest metaphor,
cummings has a transcendental reverence
for the moon,
but he has a hard time pinning it down
in language.
That's why it's the shyest metaphor,
many then he attempt to understand it,
to know it will result in the symbol
fleeing further away.
This is what the moon has always meant
to cummings and it's the way he feels
about love and poetry too,
in his notes which are collected at
Harvard,
he once wrote to know is to possess and
any fact is possessed by everyone who
knows it.
Whereas those who feel the truth are
possessed,
not possessors like the great American
transcendentalists.
Cummings believes truth in poetry and
love cannot be comprehended,
only experienced with his poetry and all
its intense experimentation.
He attempts to short circuit our impulse
toward knowing so that we might
experience language.
A new I carry your heart is a rare
attempt at clarity and form and content.
It points toward love just as it points
toward cummings philosophy,
but it's true.
Magic is in the way it unfolds
effortlessly in a rhythm and cadence.
Harmonious with feeling.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I want to point you guys in the
direction of a channel that I really
love wisecrack we've been pushing back
and forth to each other because I think
if you like my stuff,
you're definitely going to love what
they do.
They do eight bit philosophy,
thug notes,
but I've really been loving earthling
cinema,
which is like film analysis from the
perspective of a crabby but hilarious
earthling from the future.
I'm a,
I don't know.
I'm a sucker for high concept stuff and
it's really smart.
Um,
anyway,
go to their channel.
Watch this one that they just did on Mad
Max,
which is really good.
Um,
and subscribe and tell them the nerd
writer sent you in comments.
Um,
yeah,
they're,
they're just good people.
Uh,
anyway,
if you want to,
to the nerd writer directly,
you can click right here.
Go to my patrion.
Um,
I just started a blog on patriots.
So if you a pledge dollar per video,
you can get access to that,
some behind the scenes stuff.
That's cool.
Um,
anyway,
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.